[Musique]
émond grecs aujourd'hui à ma caméra
cachée il m'a piégé et à guillotin avant
tous les autres avant tous les autres
c'est vrai que j'étais le premier piéger
et il avait pour un rendez vous pour
parler de tpm p c'est ça et puis je me
suis dit avec ton collègue lionel stan
ou qu'il était préférable d'être piégé
avait quelque chose pour entrer pour une
entrée en matière exactement à certains
auteurs latins que j'aurai mes pieds je
vais aussi on n'a pas eu le temps de
leur botteur pierre ça c'est mieux pour
ta santé filles qui arrivent
robin gpec les isight et abete a été
adorable en fait je crois qu on lui elle
m'avait dit tu verras cyril adore les
tarés et ça va pas manquer j'adore ça
cyril hanouna piégé première fois on est
sur youtube avec la chaîne nous qui
cartonne moi j'aime beaucoup ce que vous
faites est ici aussi tout merci merci
nous envient voilà on a envie de faire
des choses avec vous a dit kylie mais
alors direct sur youtube moi j'ai envie
de me frotter à la hâte et la shdm et
des ongles c'est plus pour l'aspect
thune pour parler vraiment franchement
par contre je me vois pas être au niveau
de cas plus d anjou aux motards de la
sécu tu vois c'est un peu c'est un peux
me mettre sur un piédestal c'est un peu
difficile pour moi
on est un peu en mode de fusée en ce
moment est si on nous met là tu vois
avec des gens qui évoluent pas
d'aujourd'hui
les keynotes refusé de répéter ses
missions le plus puissant et du paf jeu
non ça c'est clair
ouais ouais bah faut pas mettre ma tête
à côté de n'importe qui et tu vois c'est
sur un plan b enfin de nom mais j'étais
nommé chevalier déroulé juste pour qu'on
sait on s'en sort pas je finis juste de
mettre quelqu'un tu un showman mais à
côté un peu bruyant tu rigole tout le
temps pour rien tu t'accroches sur un
truc pour combler un peu le vide et
l'espace et tu te fais peut-être pas
assez confiance j'ai envie de dire mais
cyril un joueur noir mat est gelée cyril
fetwa confiance quoi t'es bon quoi tu as
du talent bassam a perdu un petit peu je
suis dit elle mais comme je suis dans la
vie au contraire font pas la paix il est
sous le vent sur youtube la télé ça paye
c'est plus de pognon moi je pense que je
sais qu'ici vous avez pas mal d'argent
[Musique]
tu veux en parler tout à fait d'être
devant la tv
ouais par rapport au manque de classe et
où je parlais non je n'ai pas n'ont
jamais d'accord sur sa joie le côté sale
de l'émission pas c'est pas un truc qui
dérange au greffe
nous on fait de la télé populaire tu
veux pas comment je ramène un truc un
peu plus français
[Rires]
je sais que toi sur la télé je fais pas
l'unanimité mais tu sais il ya des gens
qui l'adorent et à des gens qui te
déteste moi sur le web
gêné là on le voit dans les dents les
commentaires j'ai rarement des critiques
et 11 et toujours ce mec c'est la crème
du web tu vois et donc je me dis si moi
je m'associe je peux terminer vraiment
mellionnec juste deux secondes du jeu si
moi je m'associe à un moment donné à un
type qui fait pas l'unanimité sur un
média qui sous-performent par rapport à
internet fauqué l'argent et que la place
sur un banc des pénalités qui sous
performent pas par rapport à saurons
avec matthieu delormeau de leurs maux
alors qu'à toulouse prend l'exemple pour
le coup ça me fait un peu grincer des
dents parce que de leur point c'est
vraiment la fin ces niveaux raccord des
chiottes donc tout ça pour dire poitrine
est ce que je te propose c'est que tu
t'appuies sur moi pour l'émission la
partie française
une fois par semaine mon grect un génie
août à dormir au neveu n'est qu'un
personnage de précieuses et peut-être